hey guys maybe a little a history of a
beer we've been around for seven years
I've been with the company six years and
we've actually developed a caching
technology to accelerate
network-attached storage some of the if
you've seen any movies in the last what
four or five years and some of the some
of the customers are here you it's we've
had something to do with it we've we've
accelerated the Nazz access from the
Renault nodes or transcode engines or
even the artists so you know we've been
we've had a bare-metal machine for a
long time and just recently over the
last eight months we've been we've
developed a virtual machine and we
pretty excited to have Google part of
that now and over the last year as well
we've developed the connector into into
any type of object storage device so
we're using s3 api to connect into any
type of you know either clever safe lamp
of data or any or any you know
software-defined storage so we're pretty
excited to have Google part of that
today
okay so the the two offerings we have
with Google and again with the version
that you know we're not new to virtual
machines at all we've actually been
using virtual machines for for a number
of years our QA and engineering team use
our own virtual machines running a beam
where as a matter of fact to do any any
engineering QA so it's you know it keeps
the cost down for building out you know
hardware to do that some of the some of
this Google offering is pretty cool
because we can you know the storage that
you can use is just infinitely
expandable and the community the compute
engines that you would use for rendering
is is you know expand that out to to
whatever you want so what we do is we we
offer up a file system from we're
approaching to a file system either from
an object store device or some other
type of nas type of device so we offer
UPS NFS assists to the to the clients
and it could be artists it could be
render nodes it could be transcoding
engines and then in turn we talked NFS
and the s3 API back to the storage
device some of the target industries
is our media entertainment life sciences
and financial services we've been like I
said we've been around for a long time
we have a number of hundreds of
customers out there the early adopters
were media and entertainment so I think
that's why this is going to be pretty
interesting this offering from Google so
what I'm gonna do I'm going to kind of
talk about configuration here and if
there's any questions if I don't cover
something please ask me you know later
on so down on the initially that the
like I said we had a bare-metal
appliance the bare metal appliance was
installed on prime of course and the
reason for that is to is to offload that
nass product whatever type of you know
those legacy and navs banners you have
from the IEEE ops that these render
nodes were beaten the living
you-know-what out of the of the storage
so we're offloading all that stuff now
then what I mean is that we're putting
the active data set into our tier we're
a caching appliance we're a proxy of the
file system we have multiple different
mediums inside of the inside of our
devices we have DRAM for you know fast
access we have NVRAM for rights we have
SSDs and SAS drives so we move data back
and forth between these different
mediums depending on the act of data set
and how you know what what the needs are
from the render nodes in the and the and
whatever other clients so on the bottom
half of this slide you'll have the your
on-prem storage you have your render
render farm as well as your artists and
on the right of that that you have the
Naza and object storage device not
necessarily say that you would have an
object storage device but that's
something we think will be a pretty
impressive going forward because the you
know the Naza benders cost is getting
kind of over the top on the top we have
the Google compute engine so if you you
know we talked about burst computing a
little little earlier on and you know if
you don't have enough hardware on Fram
in order to its finish the jobs that you
have it'd be great to be able to spin
something up into the into you know it's
a Google compute in addition to that you
could use Google storage as well but the
thing is is that in order to do
something in order that in order to
really utilize the compute farm in
Google you have to be able to get the
data up there
so what are what our device is again
remember I mentioned it's a proxy well
what that means is if a request comes in
either the bare-metal machine or the or
the virtual image and we don't have it
it's a cold cache hit we're gonna go
back and get it from the storage so on
the bottom if that was a bare-metal
machine if the render nodes make a
request for something say it's a new job
a new render I've got a couple shots at
your rendering we're gonna go back to
the NAS product and grab it and stick it
in there and we're going to keep it
there forever until there's competition
for space because you know obviously the
job's gonna finish and something else is
gonna be more important the same thing
happens for the virtual machine okay on
the top left we have the Google Google
compute and what we've done is we've
utilized our software to live within to
build a virtual machine cluster we're a
clustering solution we have high
availability so you can build this
cluster out the 50 I'm not I don't have
a customer that has 50 in a cluster I
think the large cluster I've seen is
will 21 but you know that's not usually
normal but in any event you can you can
scale this cluster within Google compute
depending on how many I ops you're
trying to drive with your particular job
so those those that that virtual cluster
can also access the on-premise storage
so again you don't have to copy data up
into the cloud and leave it there you
can you can just fire off your job we're
gonna go back to the on-prem storage and
grab that data and shove it into our
cache and keep it there we're gonna
replicate that data amongst all those
virtual nodes and serve it as you know
parallelizing it note to the l2 the
render farm alright so when you're done
with that you know when you're done with
the with the job I need to output that
you can write it back to the Google
Cloud storage or you could write that
back all the way down to on Prem we we
offer our global namespace that I'm
going to talk about the next slide that
kind of goes over you know how we can
kind of put this all together in one big
one big globe so to speak so since we're
a proxy the file systems we take the the
either the NFS exports or those buckets
from either Google Cloud storage or your
on-prem object storage device we roll
that into a filesystem we're going to
that even an object or device we're
gonna present that as NFS or SMB okay in
in in addition to that what we can do is
we can roll together a namespace around
all these different nas products for
object storage devices as well as as
well as the Google Cloud storage and
what I mean is that it's it's you know
you will that you could potentially just
mount slash at the top of the hierarchy
and just CD and change into the your
different type of the different
directories or shares that we would have
representing these different object
stores you know the buckets are also the
the on-prem storage what's really
interesting is that well global
namespace is fun and everything but I
think what's what's really compelling is
if you could do something really
interesting with it like move data
behind the scenes and the reason why we
can do that is because we we terminate
the protocols but we also offer up our
own file system IDs again we have to do
that for object storage devices anyways
because there's no files there's no such
thing as a file system ID just a common
object storage device what we do is
these buckets that are being presented
to us that we that we gather into our
namespace we look at those objects as
actually blocks so you know depending on
what object storage device is it could
be a one mega could be a four make
actually block size since since we treat
the object storage device little
differently we actually cache the data
differently than we do an ass product we
try to keep all the metadata for all
those buckets that are active and even
keep the first 16k of files we also
offer now that just came out a couple of
months ago as we offer up a snapshot for
your object or device so if you had
either an on-prem of your cluster right
that you already have and you're
accessing that you're actually accessing
the google cloud storage or you have an
on-prem or i mean a the the vir cluster
within google compute we could offer
snapshots for that so you could have you
know versioning versioning for that
particular data that you're dumping out
there since we offer up our FS IDs that
allows us to do something kind of you
know some gymnastics behind the scenes
what i mean by that is there you're able
to do a move or a mirror of data and in
this example what we're doing is we're
actually moving from your on-prem
storage whether its object or
or some type of legacy Nash product up
into Google Cloud storage so we can do
that without without anybody really
knowing in others what I mean is that
the the clients won't know any different
that something has moved because we're
we offering up the FS IDs so the FSA DS
never changed so your clients are never
going to see any type of sale on FS
handle or anything like that here's an
example of we seen a slide a little bit
earlier this is this is an example of
actually one of our customers and is
actually another there's two is one in
media entertainment there's another
customer that's that's not an immediate
entertainment what they have is multiple
locations that are accessing either you
know the Google Cloud engine for
rendering or some kind of compute of any
kind or you know also accessing the
on-prem storage and what's not shown
here is that one of the things that we
do is we eliminate the latency that your
clients are seeing when they access that
Nast order that object storage device so
since we eliminate the latency where
latency killer as well as an offload
engine we can place these bare metal
machines you know at some other location
so in this instance you know there's
people here in the crowd here that are
using it for for remote LAN caching so
you could have la Vancouver and New York
and any other location that could have
these of your bare metal machines
caching either for something that's
stored in Google Cloud storage or
actually caching for your on-prem
storage that would be in a different
location
so most initially the customers bought
but the bare metal machines for just on
Prem acceleration and ever ever since
then after after we came out with the
the feature of LAN caching they're
actually putting us at other locations
so what that means that you can have
people in Vancouver working which is
happening you know do the tax incentives
or like you know like rodeo FX's and
Quebec and Montreal and everywhere else
but the storage is living at some
central location so this is the product
line we have the the Google virtual fxt
and that has a
a certain size of DRAM and SSD and and
and then we have the hardware off to the
right and we have we have three models
right now and the farthest one the right
is the 4850 it's the highest performing
model because it's full of SSDs the the
kind of the flagship product is 3850
which is has a mixture of SSD DRAM and
SAS drives for the coldest data what we
do is since we have these multiple
different you know types of media we
actually move data demote it and promote
data back and forth depending within
those media types depending on how you
know what the clients needs are so that
in mind we also have an Envy around card
in the heart and a bare-metal machine so
some of the tests we've done with the
Google the virtual image that runs at
Google compute is that it's the speeds
are really really close to what the bare
metal will alow and bare metal machine
that we have the only thing that's
different is the writes it's because we
don't have there's no there's an envy
ram card in the Google compute yet so we
have to commit those rights the SSDs but
other than that the reads are you know
maybe you know eighty ninety percent of
what the of what the bare metal machines
are so just to recap you know the
connector that we use to talk to the
storage is NFS d3 or we use the s3 api
which is what we're using talk to the
global Google Cloud Storage we can scale
this the bare metal cluster or the
virtual cluster up to 50 not that you
would do that you know it's you have to
have you know 150,000 nodes or something
to be able to you know spin up your
cluster up to 50 and we have a one of
the other things that we probably should
have had a slide on is a statistics that
somebody mentioned about statistics a
little earlier on this morning we have
about 10,000 statistics that we can
present
it's just dizzying and the things that
you can gather and the reason why we can
gather these statistics is we kind of
have we're going to we're in the data
path of course but we have our head
above water and below water so to speak
right because we we understand what the
clients are doing and we also understand
what the the backend storage device
weather sonar bigstar's of device or at
NASA
so we can tell you you know what's
happening with the with the core filers
we can tell you what the clients are
doing and more importantly we can drill
right down to tell you what the hot
clients are at any pretty good point in
time we can tell you the rate of Io and
what that IO is we can we can drill down
even deeper and tell you what the
clients are doing so we can give you a
list of the hot clients and we can tell
you what what type activities you're
doing are they doing you know are they
doing region doing right so they're
doing directory updates okay we can tell
you the path of the file to do that and
you can gather that through our
dashboard our UI or you can actually get
use it use our API we have an API based
on XML RPC that you can use to to gather
all that data and put into any other
tools that you that you might you might
be using today